- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here.
Welcome to the Homeroom live stream.
Before we jump into our
very exciting conversation
with our guest Marley Dias,
I'm, I'll give my standard
announcements or reminder
that we are not for profit organization.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making a donation
at khanacademy.org/donate.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
Also wanna give a shout out
to several organizations
that have stepped up.
We were already running a
deficit pre-Covid, Covid hits,
our costs go up even
further, so special thanks
to Bank of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, Novartis
and many of our supporters,
large and small.
Thank you for that help.
It's what allows us to keep going
and serve tens of millions of
students around the planet,
but we also do need more
help, especially for 2021.
So if you're in a position to
do so, please think about it.
And then my last announcement, reminder
that this aversion of this live stream
is available in podcast form
Homeroom with Sal the podcast,
wherever you might find your podcasts.
So with that,
I'm super excited to introduce
our guest Marley Dias.
She's an author.
She's the founder of #1000BlackGirlBooks.
Marley, thank you for joining us.
- Thank you for having me.
- I think you might be our
youngest guests so far,
so you've already set a record (chuckles).
- I wouldn't be surprised, I
hear youngest all the time.
- Okay. (chuckles)
You should enjoy it
because I used to hear that
and I don't any longer.
(chuckles)
So, so, you know, there's,
there's a bunch of
really interesting things
that you've been working on and
maybe a good place to start.
Explain what #1000BlackGirlBooks
is and why you started it.
- So at campaign I've launched this called
1000 Black Girl Books and it has the goal
of collecting and donating books
where black girls are the main characters
to communities across the world.
And this originated from
me being a lifelong reader,
loving to read so much in fifth grade,
but my teacher not having diverse books
within our assigned
readings and reading lists.
So I knew from my personal experience,
loving to read at home, that
there were so many stories
that included the
experiences of black girls
and people of color
and people with different
experiences than mine.
But when I went to school,
I never had access to the
stories that I valued so much.
So with 1000 Black Girl Books
my original goal was to collect 1000 books
where black ghosts like me
were the main character.
And now over the past five years,
I've collected 13,000 books
where black girls are the main characters
and been able to donate thousands
to not only promote
diversity and inclusion,
but to also show to other
kids that it is possible
to care about something
super deeply at a young age,
and to pursue it with the
help of your community
and the help of your parents.
- And I wanna double click on that,
but I wanna remind everyone
watching, you know,
whether you're watching
on Facebook or YouTube,
please put questions in,
our team is looking at 'em.
We will surface them to Marley
or myself if applicable,
but I wanna double click
on what you just said,
because I think there's
a lot of fifth graders,
you know, 10 year olds,
which is when you started,
who will look at the world
and say, I wish the world
was a little bit different.
I wish I could change that aspect,
but they're like, "I'm 10
years old, what can I do?"
I mean, I know 30 year
olds who think that way,
I'm 30 years old, what can I do?
much less if I'm 10 years old.
What was it in your mind when you were 10
and said, no, I think I
can make a difference.
And how did you do that?
How did you put one foot
in front of the other
and start making progress
towards this initiative?
- Well, I think that's
a difficult question
because although I had created something,
I wasn't always confident
that I would be able to achieve it.
So the reason I had a thousand is
because in my fifth grade
mind, not knowing, you know,
like all of the numbers
that I can count to,
I thought a thousand was
the largest number I could think of.
So I felt like that was
a reasonable goal for me,
reasonable yet egregious.
So I think for a lot
of kids, they come, it,
it really starts with research
and understanding the problem.
So at first I thought that only my school
and only my school in
West Orange, New Jersey
was the only school that wasn't diverse.
But as soon as I complained to my mom,
she was explaining to me that
her parents had this issue.
My dad's great-grandparents had this issue
and that it exists in a
larger scheme of things.
So I think my first step for
kids before they decide to
take action or step out
somewhere and try to protest
and fight against something
or to fight for something,
is to do more research
and to understand the ways
in which this problem exists
in your community and
then in the whole world,
and then kind of a larger
grand scheme of things.
- And how did that happen?
So it sounds like, you
know, your first step
you started talking to
your parents about it.
You learned that this was a broader issue
than just what you're facing
at your school or your area.
I at age 10, I mean, how
did you say well, okay.
What, how did you decide to take action?
What was some of,
what were some of those
first steps that you took?
- One of the first steps was figuring out
what books do I have in my home
that I think every student should have,
or what books do I really care about
that I think public schools need.
So it was "Brown Girl
Dreaming" by Jacqueline Woodson
my favorite book at the time.
And my mom had, and she's
still one of my favorites,
but I'm not 10 anymore.
So it's not necessarily
my favorite right now.
I, my mom would make me take pictures,
posing with the books.
And what we would do is
she had an office space
and we would post the places
you could send the books.
And I would say,
my daughter, Marley is a lifelong reader.
She really loves to read,
but she cannot find books
where black goes with the main character.
So after I understood that,
Oh, Marley faces this issue,
but thousands of people
of color across the nation
faced this issue as well,
please send to here and
here, if you can donate.
Now, people may think that I got
an outpouring of love and
support in the first month,
but I did not.
I got some family, friends here,
some random people on the internet here.
And it wasn't necessarily
what I had expected
that I would reach a thousand
and become this large success.
And now I've learned to cheat that
over a longer period of time.
But I think for a lot of kids,
it's about using the
power of social media,
asking your parents to say,
"Hey, can I talk to my
teachers and ask them
"if we can put a drop, a
drop box in our classroom?"
"Hey, can I talk to my
principal and my track coach
and my soccer coach."
So a lot of the times it's
really reaching out to people
that already exist within your space.
And I use social media because
I know it was a helpful tool
for people that may live super far away,
but it's also important
to reach out to people
that we know our posts,
people that are our postman, our teachers,
and our community members.
- I think there's two layers
at which your initiative
is really interesting.
One is the direct layer
that you're talking.
I mean, maybe actually three layers.
There's the need to collect, you know,
a thousand plus books for
maybe your local community,
your local schools.
I think there's a point in the signal
that it sends to the broader world
that like we should have more diversity
in the books we read.
And I'd actually think
the other meta point
is what we're talking about,
which is that, you know,
someone between the ages of 10 and 15
has a lot of agency in this world,
maybe because of social media,
maybe because of other things
to actually get people thinking
and get getting people to take action.
When did you realize that this was more
than just a little project
where you're, you know,
saying, "Hey, let's get some books."
It's kind of a book drive.
When did you say,
Hey, this is going to
really mean something,
and I should put more energy into it.
- So I started a campaign
in November of 2015,
and that was me sitting
at the diner with my mom,
complaining to her about how
much I thought fifth grade
could have been better with better books.
And then after months and months,
and I, my goal was in February,
I had collected only about 200 books
within the span of three or so months.
And I was so disappointed in myself,
but towards the beginning of January
and kind of early February as well,
there were people in Philadelphia
that were reaching out
for me to do radio interviews
and to talk about this.
And when people started
mentioning that this was
more of a systemic issue
and that the idea of not having
diversity within classrooms
existed for decades before my generation,
I thought, was when I realized
maybe this can connect to
more people than I imagined,
because I really only
thought at the beginning
that it would be teachers
that understood the problem
that we're in classrooms and students,
but then understanding that, you know,
everyone in the United
States has to go to school
at some point.
And now we're kind of forcing people
to think back on their experiences
and to realize that
there were so many inequities they faced,
and now you can help a
young person like me,
who is now experiencing these inequities,
hopefully stop them
and stop them for future
generations of students.
So it was when I heard
my grandparents saying
that they experienced this
and hearing my parents say
really opened my eyes to the idea
that I could connect with more people.
And my story could matter
to a lot more people
than I had imagined.
- Yeah, I mean, that's an understatement
and you know, it's funny.
Cause even when you get, you know,
200 books in a few months,
it's not a, it's not
a smaller achievement.
- It's not (indistinct)
I want people to know that
I was not happy with it
because a thousand is not 200,
but my parents said that
even if I only collected 200,
we were still going to donate them.
We were still going to
pursue the original goal
because the goal is not necessarily,
it is a thousand black
girl books in the title,
but the goal is to learn how
to help change the world.
The goal is to learn how
to give back to others
and for a lot of kids,
I think because I've gained
so much media attention,
they feel as though they
have to set a thousand
as their goal, or they
have to set a million.
But in reality, it's
about taking your skills,
taking the things you love,
which for me was reading
and then applying them
to problems you face and
frustrations you have.
- No, absolutely.
I can't overstate what you just said,
you know, even the early
days of Khan Academy,
I was happy when I was
able to help two or three
of my one, one cousin and
then two or three cousins.
But in the back of my mind says
it's going to be useful for them.
It could be useful for
a lot of other folks.
And I think you're, you've gone on a very,
a very, very similar journey.
You know, there's a good question here
from a YouTube Chloe
O'Neil and it, you know,
you're clearly someone who
has a deep love of books,
you know, how have books
affected your life?
And I'll extend Chloe's question a bit,
how have they affected your life?
And you know, why do you
think this is so important,
to see yourself or to see
diversity in these stories?
- Well, I think reading is super important
for so many reasons.
I think one of the main things about
why diversity is important is because
so many kids do not like to read.
They don't find it fun.
And often reading is used as a punishment
within the household.
And we're often presented
with similar stories,
hearing this, some of the
stories I was assigned,
my teachers had read
when they were in school,
which might seem fun,
but we also need to think about
how can we change and adapt to
the ways that our classrooms now look,
the ways that technology is involved.
So reading is super important and having
and supporting so many authors
that are innovating in their writing,
because you can connect to the experiences
of so many different types of children.
The books I was reading
mainly had white boys
as the main character.
And my quote, was kind
of that I only read books
about white boys and their dogs.
And although that might seem like
it's just an independent experience
over 80% of the books published in 2015,
the year when I faced this problem,
we're about animals and
we're about white people.
So I realized now that when
we think about reading,
we have to make sure that
we show all the aspects
of different people.
Native people's lives,
black people's lives,
white people's lives,
women, girls, children,
and then make sure that we
include in our classrooms.
I'll look out into the
real world and to see
our friends, our family,
strangers that we may admire,
our heroes and that all these
people can look different
and their experiences can be different.
And difference does not mean a bad thing.
It is actually a gift to
all of us to understand
and see the perspectives
of new people and ideas.
- And you know, now that
you've gone on this journey
and you have these, you
know, many thousands of books
that you've, you've been able to get.
I mean, I'm assuming you're,
you're reading a lot of these books.
I have there been some stories.
I mean, you mentioned
one is your favorite.
I mean, what are some of the,
I've encouraged everyone
to go to your website,
thousands of black girl books,
but what are some of
your favorites and why?
- So some of my favorite personal books,
one will always be
"Brown Girl Dreaming"
by Jacqueline Woodson,
which was kind of the exit and the purpose
for starting the campaign,
because I loved it so much,
but some of my favorite picture books
I would say are probably
"Please, Puppy, Please" by Spike Lee,
I would say "President of the
Fifth Grade" by Sherri Winston
"Piecing Me Together" by Renee Watson.
I've read so many books now at this point.
And I, I always read
the picture books first
because you know, they're a
little bit easier for me to read
now that I'm 15,
but when you start to get
into those middle grade books,
especially for middle schoolers,
you realize how important that time is
because your identity starts
to develop your point of view.
You get more time to speak.
You might have a more
eloquent and articulate
and your ideas.
And I always push for that,
especially for kids that
are within, you know,
fifth grade to eighth grade
to start thinking about social
action as an everyday thing,
because now you're starting
to recognize patterns
and realize, Hey,
people said the same thing
to me in elementary school,
and I'm now facing the same
problem with middle school.
How can I stop this from happening?
So I have a resource guide.
At a website called
grassrootscommunityfoundation.org
But if you really are a little bit lazy,
you can just look up
"1000 Black Girl Books"
and it'll be there.
But it has a list of over a thousand
of the titles that we've collected
that are separated by emerging reader,
middle grade reader
and independent reader.
So if you are in that middle grade,
that fifth grade, eighth grade, three
grade three through grade five,
you can make sure that you find books
that show these interesting perspectives
and can help you find the words
to describe some of the things
you're passionate about.
- And what you know now that you've,
I'm assuming these books
you're distributing
in your local area to other places,
have what you know have you
heard from students your age,
or even younger
that said, "Oh, thank you for doing this,
"I never saw myself."
What kind of feedback
have you been hearing?
- It is, I am so happy
that I'm still able to
hear feedback online,
especially through Instagram
and DM and all these things.
But when we got to actually
travel before COVID-19,
it was so fun getting to meet kids,
because I really, really
enjoyed that experience
so much more.
I think because people
don't have diversity,
they don't necessarily
understand that it's an issue.
So we get to go to schools in Chicago,
or we get to go to
schools in Philadelphia.
It is so much fun to see kids be like,
"Oh my God, my hair looks just like that.
"Oh, I wear glasses just like this.
"Oh, I have these beautiful Brown eyes.
"And this cover of the book has a girl
"with beautiful Brown eyes."
So it's really amazing to see
black kids get to see themselves,
but it's also really cool
to get to see kids of different
races and experiences.
Talk about why my, how
much they love those books
and how much they enjoy them.
Because obviously race
is not the only thing
that is super important
about these stories,
but it matters in our everyday life,
and our differences are something
that's worth being celebrated.
So it's really awesome to see
kids that are not black girls
really understanding, empathizing with
and caring about the experiences
of girls that look like me.
- Oh, that's, that's
super, super powerful.
You know, not only are you an
avid reader and a collector,
I guess you could say a curator of books.
But now you...
- Yeah,
I could say collector
almost at this point,
you can say collector.
I have so many books now,
personal home as well
that I think you could say collector.
- I'm imagining these stacks
of thousands of books all around you,
which, your shelf behind
you is more organized,
but I, you got, I'm assuming
these thousands of books are.
(indistinct)
- I have like a whole thing full of books
because whenever I get
a signed copy from like,
especially self-published
authors or independent authors,
I keep all of them in my
home, in my personal library,
because I don't want these people to think
that they don't matter to me.
And then all the other books get donated
that we have their copies for.
So I keep every, at least
one copy of almost every book
I try to keep that I really
like and, and interested in.
- No, I'd love to see that
stack sometime, you know,
but you're not only a
curator collector of books,
but now you're going off and
you're writing now, you know,
there's another question
from YouTube Taupin Airlines.
I don't know if they're in
airlines or not, but he said,
what made you wanna write a
book or write, be a writer?
- So kind of the reason
why I wanted to write
Marley Dias gets done.
And so can you, was because
all the time I get asked,
how do you do it?
How do you do it?
What are the steps?
And it might be nice to say
it to one person, you know,
after I do an event or I talked to them
and I get to have that
independent interaction,
but I wanted to put that
information out there.
And I wrote the book when I was 12.
So it's not necessarily
the most updated version
of my methodologies or beliefs,
but it really captures the
passion and the interest I have
in social action and reading.
And it talks a lot about my family,
which is something that
is super important to me,
for people to understand
is really a part of
my guiding principles in life.
What I believe in, what I care
about and how important it is
that we have caregivers and educators
that invest in children's curiosity,
their imagination and their leadership.
And because I've had
all those experiences,
I really wanted to put it out there
and emphasize the importance
of sharing that with kids
and for kids that might
feel like it's too late.
My parents didn't help me with this.
And I don't feel like I can,
providing them with solutions
and options to work with
their friends, their families,
and other members of their community
to create social change,
to feel confident in their
ideas and to hopefully
make some meaningful impacts.
- So Marley Dias gets it done.
I mean, that actually sounds
like a political slogan.
I'll ask you about that a
little bit, but the, the,
but is that what it is?
It's kind of like a handbook of like,
Hey, if you're a young person
or actually not on a young person,
you're just a person who wants
to do stuff in the world.
You know, this is, this is one
way of tackling, it is that,
is that the goal of the book
to get more people to take action.
- Yes, the goal of the
book is to be a guide book,
but it's also really important to me.
And I, I think it's kind of
an underrated part of the book
is to celebrate the gratitude I have
for other activists
that have come before me
talking about women like Augusta Baker,
who was one of the,
she used to be a librarian for
the New York Public Library.
And she was so focused on
diversity and inclusion
post the Harlem Renaissance
and talking about Bob
Marley, who I'm named after
and Jamaican revolution, like, you know,
there's, there's so many
little tidbits I have
and the book is full of
color, it's full of pictures
and it's inclusive to people that
don't necessarily like to read.
And aren't gonna pick up a book,
that's this heavy with no pictures.
So I made sure to make it a
guide book for kids, obviously,
but then for anybody, like you said,
that's interested in changing the world
or wants to know more about me.
- It's very cool that you
were named after Bob Marley.
- I don't think my mum (indistinct)
she named me after Bob Marley, so I can,
I will never forget my Jamaican heritage
and the pride I have in being Jamaican.
- Absolutely. You know, a
question here from YouTube
and, you know, anyone who's
does something in the world,
especially something that's public
you're bound to get, you know,
have some setbacks and criticisms.
So this question from
YouTube, Yeadon Youth says,
did you experience any
negative feedback from people?
If so, how have you handled it?
- So I do experience
some negative feedback.
I think one of the, the things
I hear the most is like,
why does it have to be about race?
Why does it, like, why does it matter?
And I, I get that
question, I understand it.
But I think whenever people ask that
and they're insinuating that
something about race is bad
or talking about race,
but it's not that at all.
And I, I think the more that we make
these conversations natural,
and don't treat talking about and saying
that I'm proud to be black or saying
that I'm proud to be a white
or from any other country
or any other region.
It is a problem.
So what I try to do in this
conversation to not say
that I'm a girl of color
or a woman of color,
but I'm proud of being a black girl.
And that's the way that
I'm perceived in the world
in showing pride in who I am
is something that's
really important to me.
So it can bother me sometimes.
People say that,
because they insinuate that
talking about race is bad.
But hopefully by including
these conversations
with younger kids,
they understand that there
is something really cool
about being different from other people.
And there's something really cool
about trying different foods,
learning different dances,
understanding different types
of pair and music and culture
from new types of people
and new experiences.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, exactly your point isn't that
all the books should be black girl books,
but you're saying they should have
a reasonable representative.
(indistinct)
- And, exactly.
- So I think really important
for people to know that I'm
not trying to push anybody out.
I'm not trying to push any stories out,
but rather bring new ones
in and provide hopefully
a fresh perspective to diversity
and what that can mean in the classroom.
- And are there moments where,
you know, I have to say you,
you are like 10 times, at
least you appear more confident
than I was at your age. (chuckles)
I mean, are there moments
where you feel like, wow,
you know, I don't know
if I'm gonna be able
to pull this off or you're,
you're unsure of yourself
and how do you handle that type of thing?
- Yes, I feel that more often
than people would imagine.
And sometimes when I talk about
it, people don't believe me,
but I definitely do feel
weary of my own potential
and capabilities because I also think
because I've exceeded and I'm oftentimes
the first person to do this, or the only,
or the youngest, like we
were talking about earlier.
I definitely wanna make sure
that I show well of who I am.
And I show well of young people.
And I wanna make sure that
anytime I get an opportunity
to be of the first or
the youngest or the only
that I am a representative
of the greatness of my
generation or people like me.
And it's funny that you say that
because I was literally last
night watching your video
on summarizing quantitative data,
because I had a statistics quiz today.
So I get nervous about stuff like that.
Like any other kid, I had a
statistics quiz three hours ago,
but I was so nervous for,
and I watched her videos to help me.
So, you know, I had those
everyday things of feeling
like I'm not good enough at something,
or I'm not ready for something.
- Now well, I'm, I'm honored that you,
that you were able to leverage
Khan Academy for that.
But yeah, I mean what you're
feeling and I say it too,
because I think so many people,
you look around the world and
it seems like everyone else
has their act together.
It seems like everyone
else is so confident,
but I know for a fact, you
know, I, all of us, you know,
and I, haven't not grown it,
hopefully you'll probably be
on a better track than me,
but I'm 44 years old now.
And I still have, you know,
imposter syndrome I'm
in front of, you know,
giving a presentation to important people.
And I'm like, how did I end up here?
Like, why am I doing this?
Am I making any? (loughs)
- (indistinct) All the time.
- Am I making any sense at all?
So I think it's as important
for other people to realize
everyone thinks that, and
it's just a natural part of,
of being, being a human being.
You know, I, I do wanna, you know, I,
I wasn't joking when I said
that Marley Dias gets it done,
is a nice political slogan.
I mean, where do you see your future?
Like what, what do you wanna do?
You're 15, I mean you got time,
but it's, you're already doing a lot.
- It's not, it's not as
much time as people think,
but because I'm 15, but I am 11 three so.
- It's better than being 44.(loughs)
- I'm much better than
being 44, but I'm fine,
but I'm in 11th grade.
So it's move, things are
moving a little bit faster
than I thought,
but I've always said
that I wanted to be
interested in journalism,
and I've always been
intrigued by telling stories
I really liked to write.
And I find that that's
my most comforting hobby,
but I am better at math than
I give myself credit for.
So I'm not really sure at this point,
but my mom is shaking her
head in the background
because she, she always, anytime
I take standardized tests,
I say, I'm gonna do so well on English.
And I always like outperform
in math and never in English.
So I know that I have skills
that sometimes are untapped
because I surround myself with books.
I've always loved books.
And now I'm facing
where I have so many
things I'm interested in.
I have thought about, you know, politics
and being in public office and
helping people in that way.
But I would want to do
something that makes sure
that I'm always providing
a voice to people
that matter to me
and to hopefully help my community
in a way that is meaningful
and not artificial in any way.
- Yeah, no, I mean, I,
it's funny when you say you're 15
and you feel like things
are going by fast.
I mean, I kind of felt that when I was 15
and then all of a sudden
I wake up one morning
and I'm 44 and I'm like,
what just happened?
But anyway, hopefully,
hopefully it's less jarring.
- Hopefully that does not hurt me
because I feel that everyday I'm like,
"this week for me has gone by so fast."
And I think like this month will go by
and then the year will go by,
but I, I always make sure to
look forward to the future
and I keep my options
open because, you know,
it's really cool that the
work I've been able to do,
I've been able to meet directors.
I've been able to be
in front of the camera.
I've been able to write articles for l.com
and go and work with glamour and,
and to see so many different things
that I've always dreamed of doing.
And I hope that in the future,
I'll be able to help other kids be,
pursue these interests
and to work with them
in collaborating on creative
projects and initiatives.
- Absolutely, there's
a bunch of questions,
continue to come in about your book.
And are you hoping to write other books?
What other topics are you interested in?
- I'm not so sure about
writing other books.
I've always been interested
in that, but like I told you,
I wake, I feel like one day I'm gonna wake
and I'm going to be in college.
And I, I get nervous about
what the future may hold,
but I am completely
interested in continuing
the work that I do.
And if that involves writing a book,
I think that it would be really important
to do something like that.
There are so many other
things that people don't know,
or I haven't really talked
about when it comes to
the ways that 1000 black girl
books has changed my life
and what it's like to be a teenager
that is talking about race in a new way,
that is challenging the ideas of adults.
And I think that a book that
talks about girls like me,
and because there are
more than people know
that are interested in social action
would be something that's really cool.
- Absolutely, and you know, the
time we have left, you know,
what, what messages would you give to?
What would you tell the 10
year old version of yourself?
If you go back in time or, you know,
10 year old kids across the world
that, you know, see
something in their community
that you'd would like to fix,
what advice would you have for them?
- Well, I think one thing I
always wanna say to people
about social action is that,
I am not trying to prove
anything to anybody.
And I think for a lot of people,
they may feel motivated by the
idea that they have been told
that they're not good enough
and they're actively doing something
because someone told them they can't,
but it's also really important
to always work in the positive.
The work I do is because I love to read
and I want to see more books
where black girls are the main characters.
I don't start 1000 black girl books.
And I didn't start this campaign
because I didn't feel like I mattered.
And I had to prove to
people that I mattered.
I showed it because I love to read
and I always wanna work in the positive,
although I can frame it negatively.
I think it's really important for people
that come up with mission
statements or have frustrations
to think about what can I
do to make things better
rather than what can I take away.
So it's always super important, I think,
especially for young kids
to think more optimistically
and to lead with hope
and to lead with the idea that positivity,
and hopefully obviously understanding
the negatives of the situation,
understanding that there is
systemic racism in this country
and me not having books is a part of that.
But also understanding that
what I can do is hopefully
be a small part of this
chain of activists,
of leaders, of powerhouses, of creatives
that will hopefully break
apart this horrible system.
So I think when I talk
about 1000 black girl books,
I always wanna talk about it
as something that is great.
That is amazing.
Than rather than saying,
I'm trying to end
something that is horrible
and that is disgusting
and that is hurting me.
So I think for all kids especially,
use hope as a motivation for change
and to focus on your frustrations,
but don't let them take over
your mission statements,
your ideas, your thoughts,
and your feelings about
changing the world.
- Well, Marley, I gotta
say, I think you just,
not only inspired a bunch of
10 year olds or 15 year olds,
you inspired a bunch of adults.
Because what you just said about
focusing on positive action,
I think is a, is a wisdom
that, you know, many people,
many multiples of your age
haven't fully, fully grokked yet.
Well, thank you so much.
This was really inspiring
and refreshing conversation.
And I have no doubt that we're
going to see you much more
in the years to come.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you, I appreciate it.
- Well, thanks everyone for joining
hope you enjoyed that conversation
as much as I did with Marley.
I I'm I wasn't kidding.
I think we're going to see a lot of Marley
in the years ahead in a very good way,
in a very positive way,
but thanks for joining and
I look forward to seeing you
at the next live stream.
I think it's going to be next week,
but I will see you
then, talk to you later.
Have a good weekend.